Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome, welcome.
Today we're gonna be playing The Hunter Call of the Wild.
So like, I've always wanted to try this game out because it's basically like a hunting simulator.
And I've never been on an actual hunt hunt before.
The only thing I know about hunting is like...
Okay, it's not really hunt.
It's duck hunt.
That's like the only thing I know about hunting is from duck hunt the game.
But like, I thought it was really interesting.
I always see this game on Steam sell a lot and it does have a lot of reviews.
And then I found out it is like a very...
So the thing is, I found out that this game is a very accurate simulation of hunting.
And I was like, oh, how accurate can it be?
Well, I was reading the reviews and they're like, oh man, it feels like I'm out there right now in the woods.
Like I'm a hunter.
And it really does simulate it very well.
And like, you know, just waiting there, sitting in the grass, just waiting for the animal to approach.
And then you gotta wait patiently and everything until you hit the perfect shot.
Like you align your perfect shot to get him.
And you gotta make sure you don't spook the animals and all that stuff.
And I was like, all right, that seems like... That definitely seems like a game for me.
Because as we all know, I am very well known for my patience, my attention span, and not running around like my head was cut off.
That is 100% a go-keeper game right there.
I should play it.
I should try it out.
I did buy DLC for this game.
Because, okay, I bought two DLCs.
One was I wanted to hunt in Canada.
So there was a Yukon Valley.
And I was like, oh my god, that's Canada.
I was like, I might as well get fully immersed, you know.
So I was like, I want to go to Canada while I'm hunting.
It was either Finland or Canada.
And I was like, I should pick Canada.
And you can shoot ducks and stuff.
And then the other DLC I bought was the Golden Retriever one.
Because like, I wanted comfort.
Yeah, so I can be at home.
And then the other one I bought was the dog DLC.
Because I wanted a dog with me to go on this hunt.
I wanted dad to come there here with me.
They had like a bloodhound.
But I was like, I don't really like bloodhounds.
Because, you know, they always look like they're depressed.
So I didn't want to have that vibe going into my hunt.
So I decided to get the Golden Retriever DLC.
But yeah, anyway, I'm really looking forward to trying this game out.
In other news, in other like life update news, did you guys see that like Marvel Rivals like sneaked in a secret cosmetic update into the game?
Did you guys hear about that?
So all the men, all the men in Marvel Rivals got like,
got a Brazilian butt lift.
So they all, they flew, they flew all the Marvel characters, all the Marvel men.
They got the BPL upgrade.
They got the Brazilian butt lift surgery.
They flew them to Brazil.
They went to Brazil, guys!
They knew what we want.
And they like, uh, not only that, but they also, uh, they also enhanced Wolverine's crouch.
Did you guys see that one?
Okay, wait, wait, let me show you guys.
I, I, I thought that was fucking crazy.
Like, Wolverine also got a buff too.
I don't know if the other ones did, but I, Wolverine got, oh, I didn't know that.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
I saw it on my Twitter.
Oh man, I don't know if I like, uh, if I liked the tweet, but I don't know if I should have, but they actually, yeah, they, they, they buffed that too.
I wish I was joking, but, uh, I thought that was so fucking funny.
I was like, wait, wait, okay, the butt, I understand, like all of them needed.
I retweeted, okay, look, I retweeted the butt version because like, that's important news, guys.
That is incredible.
That, that is like, extra, extra, read all about it.
Biggest update.
Wait, wait, the day, the tweet got deleted.
Oh, I know, I did it, okay.
Okay, it didn't get deleted.
I was gonna, I was gonna worry.
I was like, oh my god, where is the retweet?
I, okay, wait, I'm gonna, I thought they deleted the butt retweet, the, the butt enhancements.
Um, oh my god, where's the, where's the crouch?
Where's the, I found, I swear it's true.
I saw it, and I was like, oh my god.
Also, for those who wanted to see it, I still can't believe, I can't, I can't believe they, like, made it perkier.
And like, they said nothing about it.
That's like, the funniest part, like, the, obviously the devs didn't want to say anything about it, but like, it was like, a secret update.
Like, the fact that, the fact that it was like, a fucking secret update, and there was no mention of it.
And they just, like, the silent buff.
All right, let's see if I can find it.
Guys, no, you don't understand, this is very important.
I, I literally, I saw the tweet of it.
I was like, oh my god.
It's like, oh, oh my god.
Let's see if I can find it.
No, guys, you don't understand.
This is, like, the most important.
All right, I can't find the tweet anymore.
I swear to god, I saw it.
I swear to god.
I saw, like, the pictures.
I, I, I, holy shit.
I saw, I saw the comparison.
It was just, like, the butt comparison, but, like, on the front.
Don't worry, I saw it too.
Thank you, thank you for the validation, guys.
I, I really appreciate the validation that you guys give me.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Here you go, guys.
Here you go.
I found it.
It's in the replies.
That's actually crazy.
Here.
I'm sorry.
It's so tough.
It's like, I don't understand.
They, they, they hired, they hired a mother.
It's like, okay, guys, people are complaining that the men aren't sexy enough, so, um, we, we need you to plump up those asses for season two.
Imagine, imagine being the modeler, and your entire job that day was to make sure their asses are more plump and then squeezable.
They understood the assignment.
They, they really did.
The day Marvel, the day Marvel rivals decided to get serious.
It's a very important job.
Um, like, I, I don't understand why, why they had to, um, okay, like, I don't understand why they had to touch Wolverine's front.
Oh my god, like, adding a bigger bulge.
Okay, um, I also, like, to the people that discovered this too, he was, yeah, Wolverine was feeling a bit insecure, and, you know, he didn't want to be, like, just a short king, you know.
Um, uh, but, like, uh, and it's, okay, and the fact that it's only Wolverine too, like, only, only Wolverine got affected in the front.
Everybody else was just for the back, like, I was like, I'm just like, okay, all right, we're really talking about equality here.
I feel like it can't just only be Wolverine, you know.
Why is it just him?
If we're all, I mean, we're gonna start going there, we might as well do it for everybody else.
Because he's a short king, you don't understand.
It's for Lord Doki.
He was trying to be comic book accurate.
Someone on, someone on the dev team was, who is a Wolverine main, and they got really insecure.
They had a very, they had a rough day with his wife.
He had a rough day with his wife, and he got really insecure, so he decided to make the perfect being.
Um, anyway, so that's, that is an important life update, guys.
I just, I had to update you guys on this, because I, it was very important.
Like, one of the most important patches any video game has ever done.
I swear to god, I have never heard of a video game, especially in a competitive game, like a competitive, like, multiplayer game, where they decide to enhance the butt and the bulge.
But like, they didn't say anything about it.
That was, that's the craziest shit.
They said nothing about it, like, it just happened.
Like, they just, even when I was in an early access, I swear to god, nobody noticed in early access, but like, maybe they sneaked it in for season two.
They know their player.
It's an extremely important update, Doki.
You don't understand.
Look, you're right.
All we see for the characters are their backside, so they are like, all right, we gotta give them more to look at, you know.
We gotta give these people more to look at, the priorities.
Aifen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I assure you, Doki, making everyone more sexy is imperative to the competency.
You're right, you're right.
I'm so, how foolish am I?
I can't believe I would judge them.
You're right.
You know what?
In fact, I feel like they could have done more.
I feel like, you know what?
They should have, if they're gonna do all that, they might as well just gave all of them twerking emotes at that point.
Like, like, they all deserve it.
Like, it's a crime to hide such a beautiful job, um, when they flew them to Brazil.
To hide such a beautiful job, and they can't even use it.
Like, you know, like, what's the point?
Why can't they just flaunt what they have?
True.
Everyone should be throwing their ass on cart.
Exactly, exactly.
Then we'll finally achieve world peace.
Uh, Momohaku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kick is a lie, but butts don't lie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Celeste, thank you for the super chat.
Imagine being at the meeting room and telling your boss why the male characters need bigger asses.
Imagine being the animation, the art director, and was like, attention all 3D modelers, this is your new assignment before season two hits.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Now Thor's cheeks truly befit a god of thunder.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Wizword, thank you for the super chat.
Hi Doki, lejoma.
I actually emailed your business email last year with stream key, scene key to call a while.
I thought you actually redeemed it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I didn't know that.
I, I bought the thing.
I bought it myself.
I bought the game myself, but all right, free, free steam key.
Let's go.
Not for me though.
I already have the game now.
I literally bought it today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
You don't understand.
The bigger bulge is integral to the character development between season one and... What happened?
What happened to Logan in season one and two?
Where did he go?
Did someone like shot him in the crotch and then he regenerated it bigger?
Like, is that what his powers are?
Who cut his dick off?
Did something happen?
Yep, he saw it.
Yes, that is exactly who.
Like, does it regenerate bigger when it gets damaged?
Like, how does that work?
How does this regeneration work?
I don't understand.
Bro's a lizard.
Depot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of cake, it's my birthday today.
Can I have a happy birthday song?
Of course you can!
Hime, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Hime.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Also, I don't know.
It got bigger when Emma Frost got introduced into the game.
Coincidence?
Maybe he did it to himself.
All right, anyway.
Anyways, let's play Hunter Call of the Wild.
Like I said, I don't really know much about it other than the Steam description and watching the trailer, so I have no idea what's gonna happen to me.
Well, I know nothing's gonna happen.
Like, 80% of the game is just nothing happening or some shit.
All right, here we go.
All right, I accept.
I already read everything.
Okay, there you go.
I have to pretend to read everything.
No.
Skip.
Okay, I don't want to connect in my account.
All right, let's see.
Yeah, I read everything.
Do you guys know I'm a speed reader?
I'm not a good speed reader.
Okay, let's see.
Not window, full screen.
19, 20.
Okay, we're not.
Okay, maybe high.
I feel like I feel like ultra it might be a little.
Oh wait, can I?
Oh wait, field of view.
I'll put it on default.
I don't know if it'll affect or anything.
Okay, motion blur off.
Depth of field, everything.
Yeah, that should be good.
Wait, oops, I forgot to save it.
Oopsie.
Wait, where's the?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's like.
Okay, there you go.
Wait, is it?
Give me.
Give me full screen.
Oh, apply.
Oops.
It's like.
Where's my full screen?
Okay, motion blur.
Default was 60, so.
Alright, my DSC store.
I mean, I bought.
Okay, where's the one?
Yeah, there you go.
See guys?
I bought the Yukon and I bought a dog.
Okay, new game.
What options do I have?
Who looks like an actor?
Oh, wait.
Alright.
I want to go to the Yukon.
Okay, Yukon Nature Reserve.
Treasures back thousands of years.
Alright, we're into Alaska from Siberia.
Wait, wait, this isn't.
Wait, what?
Yukon Valley.
Is this owned by America?
Is this Alaska?
No, that can't be it.
The Yukon belongs to Canada.
Okay, it's in Canada.
I was gonna say, why is Alaska involved?
Like, get out of here.
This is.
I was gonna be like.
Why does he have a name?
Wait, how come everybody else is like option one, two, three, four, five?
And then there's Remy.
I'm gonna be Remy.
I was like, what is America doing here?
This is Canadian territory.
It's the fucking Yukon.
Get out, Alaska.
You don't belong here.
Alright, I'm gonna be Remy because he has a name.
I want to be a real person.
Alright, let me know this sounds okay.
So, let me grab.
Oh, turn the music down?
Okay, I will.
I will when I arrive in the Yukon.
That's me.
Yeah, this entire area is Simba.
Anywhere the sun touches belongs to you.
Okay.
Is there a tutorial?
I have no idea how to play this game.
Produce just joining.
Shots missed 104 shots.
I just started the game.
What do you mean?
Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A trampede?
Welcome to Alaska?
Wait.
Oh, no, I am in Alaska.
God damn it.
I bought this just to be in Canada.
I can't believe it.
No matter where I go, I'm still in.
I'm still in America.
God fucking damn it.
Okay, let's see.
Is there no tutorial?
Did they just drop me down here and just be like, alright, you learn.
Oh, there is.
Okay.
You can probably see the look.
Just up the hill from where I dropped you.
Can I just?
There's no way.
I have to manually.
I have to manually press this.
It's always good to know where you can rest your head after
visitors.
Okay.
I don't mind which one you travel to.
Meet.
Thank you for the 20.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
I thought I could go back.
I thought I could be in Canada.
I'm stuck in America.
I can never leave.
The map is on the- When did America co-own the Yukon?
The fuck?
Did you guys just slowly expand into the Yukon?
Like Alaska is Alaska.
Oh shit, that's my meds.
Like, did you guys just slowly started like encroaching the territory like a fucking Zerg creep?
When did you guys got part of the Yukon?
Yukon is always belong to Canada.
That's where like the famous- Oh my god.
Hey, there's poop.
Oh shit.
That's a very fresh grizzly bear poop.
Oh, he's- Oh, he flew away because I was running.
There's no way Russia gave you half the Yukon.
There's no fucking way- I refuse to believe it.
I feel like you're just slowly expanding your territory as if we didn't notice because like 50% of Canada is uninhabited by real people.
So, he just slowly just- He just slowly just started spreading your fucking seed into Canadian territory.
Like, yes.
There's no fucking way.
Like, we literally have a show.
A Canadian show based off of the Yukon.
What was his name?
That like- Oh my god, I already forgot his name.
It was a Canadian show based off of like being in the Yukon and it's called- It's like about like this guy that was frozen in ice and he got unfrozen.
Yvonne of the Yukon.
Yeah, Yvonne of the Yukon.
Didn't he never say anything about the Americans?
He never- Oh, Ivan.
They never said anything about the fucking Alaskans that co-owned the Yukon.
It was always Canada.
Yeah.
All right.
You're at the top.
Can you see the outpost?
They have half of them of the Yukon.
I normally do a routine check of an outpost to
investigate.
All right.
Bear
knocking on the door.
Okay, so we don't want to die to the bear.
All right, I got that.
Okay, so that's where- Okay, so there's the grizzly bear that's just roaming around.
Like, it's not fair.
The only reason why- Okay, wait.
Let me try- Wait, I want to see what the gunshot is like.
There's nobody here anyway, so I can just shoot my gun.
You think there's, like, an animal that's just roaming around?
Maybe I'll find an animal that's just casually roaming.
Where are they?
There's nobody here.
Where are all the animals?
There's no way there's no animals just around my surroundings.
No, I have four- Don't worry.
I have four or five bullets.
It's fine.
Is there nothing around me?
A wind and there's bullet troughs?
Okay.
Okay, we're really hunting now.
Don't understand.
How is there nothing but around me?
There has to be, like, a little rabbit or something.
Why would you protect this area if the animals aren't thriving and fucking and making more animals?
What's the point?
All right, let's see.
So that's my men's.
What is this?
Okay, now I know that, but like, what am I holding right now?
Oh, it's a duck call.
Any ducks?
Hello?
I'm just a vulnerable duck right now.
Oh, I'm so- Oh, wait.
Is that- Oh, those are the bear tracks.
I'm gonna examine.
Be very, very quiet.
I'm hunting bears.
Airborne Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You need to actually track animals to find them in this game?
Oh shit, I didn't know that.
Oh my god, it's just like- That's not- Oh my gosh, what do you mean you have to track animals?
This is the wild.
Animals should be, like, everywhere.
They should be around me.
What's the point of protecting them if I can't- If I can't kill them for my pleasure.
What's the point?
Oh, okay, that should make noise, right?
All right, I'm following these bear tracks.
Johnny Lacone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, hear me out.
Dookie Bear, who do you with?
Oh, he's over here.
He's trotting along.
He's over here.
Dookie, you're not a troop.
Wait, what am I?
Wait, people hunt for not pleasure?
Then what's the point of hunting?
Wait, what's the point of hunting?
Like, I feel like if it's not for- Like, it can't be for food.
You can just go and buy that now.
Food?
You just go to the grocery store.
There's no way I'm hunting a fucking bear for food.
I'm- I'm calling invasive.
He lives here!
How is he invasive?
This bear lives here.
I'm literally trying to kill Winnie the Pooh right now.
Wow, he's like trying to eat his honey.
Again, my local market doesn't sell bear.
All right.
Okay, he's somewhere around here.
Dookie!
Bear's a known squatter.
He didn't- Mr. Pooh didn't pay rent.
Ever since he went public domain, he thought he can squat here for free.
He missed his final notice, so I'm here to get the job done.
Yeah, this is- this is Monster Hunter, guys.
This is called, uh, uh, this is Realistic Monster Hunter.
All right.
Where did his tracks go?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll catch Mr.- I'll catch the squatter.
He lives here.
Dookie, this is America and that bear is trespassing on private property.
Wait, this is very old.
Where did he go?
Wait, do I have to go here?
Where's there?
Place waypoint.
Oh, I have to go.
Okay, I guess I'm not JK.
We're not going to the bear now.
We have to go.
We have to go back home.
All right, I'll be back.
Sorry, I was too busy trying to complete my job as, um, um, a dead collector.
All right, I'll be back, Mr. Pooh.
You think you could just squat here in my private property like that?
Welcome to America.
All right.
Okay, let me turn up the game a little bit for us.
All right, let me know if this is better.
All right.
Oh, bother.
All right, I'm heading over.
I'm gonna start running.
No freeloaders.
I have to go home to get my, get my car.
I know it
might seem trivial, but can you take a look at the trash can and make sure that it's locked?
It's a bear proof trash can with a tricky catch.
I don't want to take any chances.
All right, I'm gonna check the trash, but wouldn't I want the trash to be open?
So like, oh it is open.
Yeah.
Okay, let me close it.
Oh my god.
That's so loud.
Or I'm claiming this post like it's a fa- Like, like what was that other game?
The game where I had to claim posts and stuff?
And I was hunting in the wild?
One last thing.
Before you move on, can you take a look at the- For Far Cry.
Yeah, I like Far Cry.
This is basically Far Cry, Far Cry 3.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So these are my, all my guns.
Oh, I should have bought DLC for guns.
Where's my dog?
My dogs.
Wait, what?
I have to buy a dog?
I already bought you!
What do you mean?
Oh wait, it's free.
Okay, nice.
Oh nice, it's already free.
Okay, buy a name.
Okay, nice.
Doki Amber Doge.
Dad.
Okay.
Wait, actually yeah.
Dad.
Doki Amber Doge.
You're a big boy now.
Okay, sorry, I can't do that.
All right, I can't, okay.
Dad.
All right.
Yay!
All right, come over here.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are!
Look, it's him!
What a good boy.
Okay.
Okay, so I have to...
Yeah, he dyed his hair.
He's going through a midlife crisis right now, so he dyed his hair blonde.
And got a Ferrari.
Oh my god, I actually... Wait, I actually have a tutorial now.
Hello, dad!
You got a Ferrari and like a motorcycle.
Hello!
Who's a good boy?
You are!
That's right, it's you!
Let's play!
Come on!
Oh no!
You're already smarter than me!
Oh my god, thank god you went through your midlife crisis.
You're already smarter than you were like yesterday.
All right, who's a good boy?
Oh, yes, you are!
All right, it's used as it can also be currently tabbed to bring out the hunter mate.
Oh my god, it's my iPhone.
Okay, travel.
Wait, I have to go somewhere else.
Oh my god, when do I hunt?
Why am I doing errands?
What?
Okay.
Why am I doing errands?
I thought it was all... I thought I was supposed to be hunting.
All right, it's over here.
All right, dad.
Come over here.
Come here.
Come here, boy!
Why are we idling?
Come with me!
All right.
Let's see you.
Oh my god, lay down.
Come on, lay down.
Good boy.
Good boy, dad.
All right.
Retrieve.
What is he retrieving?
I don't know.
Get me something.
You go get something.
I don't know what you're... okay, he's gone now.
Guys, what the... what is the bear gonna do?
Use my fucking bed?
I have nothing in this house.
Like, oh, he's gonna get a gun?
He's gonna... he's gonna shoot me with my gun?
I'd like to see him try.
You know what?
I'm opening that door.
Let's fucking fight.
Did he... did my dog went to get milk and cigarettes?
Like, what are you retrieving?
What?
What is he... what are you retrieving?
What are you trying to get?
Did you get anything?
All right, sit.
Sit.
Come on, boy.
Let me push you right here so I can see you, but let me...
push you right here.
So, you wanna go on a swim?
Boy?
I'm gonna teach you how to swim today.
You wanna swim, boy?
You wanna swim?
Into the lake you go.
It's okay.
He's a really good swimmer.
Wait, can he die?
Wait, is he okay?
All right, lay down.
Oh, okay, okay.
He's getting out.
No.
Good boy.
See?
You see?
A good... a good soldier right there listens to orders.
He's very loyal.
See?
He's a good... he's a really good boy.
Please help me.
I am underwater.
All right.
Uh, good boy.
Oh my god, you are such a good boy.
That's right.
You... you are a good soldier and a very loyal one.
All right.
All right, come on, boy.
Come on.
What's... why is he healing?
Why are you healing?
What's going on?
Sit.
Come on.
Are you okay?
Is it because I made you sit in the water?
Come on.
You know, it was just a joke, right?
Oh, he leveled up!
He's awesome!
He likes it!
He likes it, guys!
Because you... no, no, no!
He... yeah, I made him stronger.
Guys, I... I made him stronger.
He leveled up.
Now, he can breathe underwater longer, guys.
Nice.
Hey, good job!
See?
Showing affection towards your dog will increase his focus regeneration.
See, guys?
That's affection right there.
That's how you love a dog.
All right, good boy.
Who's a good boy?
Who didn't drown?
Oh, you are!
That's right!
Dad, you didn't drown!
You're such a good boy!
All right, come on, let's go.
Follow me.
How do I make him follow me?
Come on.
This is all about following me.
All right, come on.
Come on, follow me.
Why don't you want to follow me?
Come on, let's go.
Let's go.
We're gonna go hunting today.
Oh, we just walk away?
Okay.
If you walk away, it'll make them want you more.
Okay, includes bushes, hides you, but it's... oh, okay.
Wait, but he's not following me.
Wait, did I tell him to stay?
No, I didn't.
I just told him to sit.
That's different.
All right.
Oh, there's an animal call.
Okay.
Uh, do not sit anymore.
Stop sitting.
Okay, stop.
I'm petting you.
You stop sitting.
You understand?
How do I make you stop sitting?
Okay, lay down.
Okay, uh...
Retrieve.
All right.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now he's gonna retrieve stuff.
I don't know what he's gonna retrieve.
Oh my god.
No, don't drown yourself again!
No!
That was just a...
Stop!
Come back!
You're strong enough!
No!
What are you doing?
He's crossing...
Don't go to Canada!
You don't have a passport!
They're cracking down on people legally crossing the border now!
We don't have... We're not friends with them anymore!
We're not friends with them anymore!
Come back!
You can't go to Canada!
They're gonna deport you back!
They're gonna...
He's going... He's crossing the border.
He's going.
He's retrieving.
They're gonna deport you!
And it's not gonna be to Alaska!
This is what happens when Dookie's dog isn't confined.
Come back!
He's like, go get him, champ!
Dad is retrieving Canada!
He's gonna get the job done!
Come back here!
Okay, all right, let's actually let's... we're just... okay, I have to go there.
All right, we gotta go in there.
He's gonna take Canada back.
He's gonna make Canada the 51st state with a one dog army.
He'll follow me, right?
Oh, he's gonna follow me.
I believe in him.
Look at him.
He's swimming back.
He realized he can't do this alone.
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who wants to visit a babysitter really bad?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's go to... is he following me?
Oh, he is.
Okay, nice.
That's right.
Come over here.
We're gonna go.
We're gonna go to get some wood.
This is like... it's not even a hunt.
Oh, wait, there's deer.
Wait a minute.
Okay, wait, I want to hunt deer.
Forgotten, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, let's get the deer tracker.
All right, I know I should be retrieving wood, but like there's deer prints here.
This might be my first kill.
I'm slowly walking over because I don't want to spook anything.
Don't worry.
I'm heading to the... I'm very slowly walking to the deer tracks right now.
I'm gonna make it.
Don't worry.
It's like right here.
I see it.
It's like right over here.
My binoculars can see it.
Yeah, I do.
I have a gun.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
That's not it, but...
So he knows that I'm just a bird.
I have no idea what this thing I'm holding.
Okay.
It's this way.
Wait, those are... Wait, those are bear tracks.
What?
Where's the deer tracks?
I walked all the way here for more bear tracks?
All right, never mind.
See, I have a gun.
It's right here.
See, there's my gun.
It's gonna be so... Okay, he is trotting.
I can take him.
Okay.
It's time to get the squatter.
He thinks he can live in my nature reserve and not pay rent?
I bet... I bet he doesn't even have a passport here.
I bet he's from the... I bet he's from on the bad side of the Yukon.
The Canadian side.
But you're right, I need to wear something real quick.
Give me a sec.
You're right, I'm forgetting.
Guys, I'm just role-playing, okay?
I'm just role-playing.
I realize I should... I should be fully immersed.
All right, here we go.
Too real.
A gun's a gun.
What do you mean?
I have a shotgun.
I need to have a different gun?
Is he following me?
Okay, he is.
Okay, he ran that way.
Where the fuck this guy...
Wait, but there's a deer here.
Wait.
Deers are... Wait, no.
Bears are slower.
Bears are actually slower though, so I'm gonna go for the bear.
All right.
He can't be that far.
He has to be.
Bears are slower than cariboos.
Cariboos run... Wait.
Oh.
Shh, there's a duck.
It's duck season.
Be very quiet.
Hey, where is this duck?
Shh, be very, very quiet.
It's...
What if I shoot him with a fucking pistol?
Where is this duck?
I hear you.
I'm just like you.
I'm also a duck.
Look, see?
Okay, so the bear drinks here at a specific time.
You hear that?
You hear that, dad?
He drinks here at a specific time.
Okay, it's very old.
Wait, but what time does he drink here?
Drinking at four to eight.
Wait, what time is it?
Does my phone tell me what time it is?
Oh, okay, it's past four.
Oh, god damn it.
He was here an hour ago.
God damn it.
Okay.
All right, he's not here anymore.
Where the fuck is this bear?
Hello?
Where are you?
I think that's how bears... is that how bears sound like?
Is that... is that...
I think that's how bears sound like, right?
I lost the tracks though, by the way.
I don't know where the tracks are.
All right, maybe the tracks will appear again when I head to the story mission.
It's like 900 meters away.
It's not that far.
Maybe dad will find the bear.
Hello?
I haven't seen a single animal in this nature preserve.
Like, did we kill them all?
Like, where are you?
Not even like a fucking duck.
Okay.
I want to run, but I'm worried that I run and the bear was like next to me the whole time.
He like teleports behind me or some shit.
Wait, there's a question mark right here.
I don't make a lot of noise.
I'm literally walking!
I'm walking and there's... okay.
I'm making duck noises.
That's different.
I'm just like them.
I'm just like you!
I'm a duck!
All right.
Wait, human walking is also...
Oh, it's a red fox.
Okay, warning call.
What are you gonna warn me about, huh?
You think I'm scared of you?
Oh shit.
I need to buy wood?
Okay.
Okay, that is a gray wolf.
I heard a duck.
I heard a duck near me.
Hello, I'm just like you!
Quack, quack!
Just like you!
Quack, quack, quack!
He ran that way.
Why are you all so scared?
I just... It's just me.
I'm just here to pay... I'm just here to get rent.
Guys, as long as you pay rent, you'll be fine.
There's nothing to worry about.
Little guys...
As long as you pay rent.
Bro, I don't fucking care.
I'm not hunting you.
Wait, this is a coyote?
I'm just like you!
I'm part of the dog family!
Okay, they were here.
There was a lot of them here.
Let me blow my nose real quick.
Guys, there's nothing to be afraid of!
If you pay your rent, you don't have to worry about me.
I'm just here to collect rent!
You think...
You think living in this nature preserve...
is for free?
Who's paying for all these trees, huh?
Who's paying for all your food?
Okay, he's right here somewhere.
Oh, there's a lot of them trotting around.
Wait, it's snowing.
Oh my god.
Okay, they must not have gone too far.
Yeah, and who pays taxes?
I'm trying.
Me and I'm trying really hard.
I'm trying really hard to try and pay my taxes right now.
I'm still waiting 15 days.
Still waiting for those 15 days.
To get my fucking letter.
All right.
I want to find- I want to see at least one thing.
I just- I just want to see wha- The fuck is right there!
God damn it!
He looked at me!
He saw me!
It was so close!
He blew the- no!
It was right there!
I was just walking around quacking!
Oh my god.
I saw him though, guys.
I did see him.
Not today, landlord.
Oh my god.
We got a runner.
Dad, why didn't you say anything?
I found- I found a guy who missed last month's friend and he ran.
He knew.
He knew what was gonna happen.
What does my phone say?
Okay, I'm trying to head- I'm gonna head to the wood lodge.
We got a runner.
I'm running.
Fuck this.
There's no way that like- I have any of them close to me.
I refuse to believe that.
They help you retrieve or track wounded animals?
Why are they retrieving?
What is he retrieving?
I told him to retrieve and he tried to swim to Canada.
Like, I don't know.
Tux usually.
Alright.
He was retrieving the taxes.
He wanted to retrieve Canada.
Yep, that's my golden retriever right there.
That's fine.
There's no way the animals heard me running, right?
I haven't seen- I saw only one animal and it was the moose.
That ran away.
That's fine.
Oh.
He's a hundred meters away.
I'm heading over.
I literally ran a little- Okay, guys.
Be very quiet.
Oh.
Oh, it's right there.
I see him.
Guys, do you think he'll reach it?
It's right there.
Oh my god, where did he go?
Be very quiet.
We're gonna hunt wolves now.
I pivoted a lot, but this is the final pivot.
I swear to god.
They're like right there somewhere.
Where are they?
I lost them.
I don't know how.
They were literally right in front of me.
They were literally right- Oh, there they are.
Oh.
Why are you barking?
Okay.
Very easy.
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Do you think they know?
Wait, they're not running away.
Wait.
Oh shit, he wants to fight!
Yeah, you wanna fight?
Yeah?
Yeah, that's fucking right!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh wait, he's dead.
Okay.
Oh, it was just that easy.
Okay, nice.
I got a wolf.
That's right, I got your alpha!
What you gonna do now?
That's fucking right!
Oh, they got very hard?
That's right!
I got the alpha!
I'm gonna taxiderm it.
Okay, I can't.
I'm broke as fuck.
That's right!
Run!
You see that?
Now retrieve it.
Alright, what's the trophy rating?
3236.
Oh, did I got like- Oh my god, I got a gold trophy!
Okay, harvest.
Improper animal for this animal.
Animal shot more than two times.
Whoops, okay.
Whoops, my bad.
I have to have like proper fucking- Okay, how do I- What do I do?
I ruined the gold?
How do I make it- Look, I almost got gold though.
I was two points away.
Alright, I hit his flesh.
Right humerus and right scapula.
And then his intestines.
Oh, I can't use a shotgun?
But he was like right there.
He was right in front of me.
That's fucking right.
You try to hunt me, I hunt you back.
Alright, do I save harvest?
Is that what I do?
Inspect.
I tore it up.
Ooh, look at that.
You can x-ray a trophy?
Oh, wait.
How do I x-ray it?
I got silver though.
Oh, right click?
What does H do?
Right click for x-ray?
Whoops.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I shot him right here.
Okay, I should've went like- Where's his heart?
Oh, I almost got the heart.
It was literally like if I shot like right here, it would be the heart.
That was so close.
I was literally that close to the heart.
He was like so close to me!
Okay.
Wait, look for a green glow?
There's a green glow?
What does that mean?
Wait, do I press H?
To save harvest for it?
Do I just press save harvest?
Oh, I can see the...
Oh, you know what?
You know what?
Okay, press enter.
I'm not gonna taxiderm him.
No, I should.
Wait.
Okay, I'll save harvest.
Okay, there you go.
My first wolf.
When I can't afford you, I shall taxiderm you.
Nice.
Look at that!
I got my first heart!
Did you see that?
Did you see that, dad?
Now you know you have to pay rent.
You think you're living in my house for free?
Now you know.
This is what happens when I have squatters living in my nature reserve.
That's right!
Your alpha is dead!
Whoa!
I think they all ran away.
I'm pretty sure.
What the fuck do you do to the squatters?
I fucking taxiderm them.
I say as a sane person.
Oh wait, I killed another one.
Wait, when did he die?
When did I kill you?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, I got a lower rating?
When did I kill this guy?
Did he bleed out?
Yeah, he has a lower difficulty.
I got him without blood loss.
Yeah, I know.
I'm not doing anything with this one.
This one's not worth it.
This guy...
Oh, is this the one I first shot?
The one I didn't shotgun to death?
It's surprising that the one I first shot has a lower rating.
The AOE kill.
Alright, the shock...
I had more points with the shotgun for the one that had more...
The one where I shotgunned.
Oh, it's because he's not the alpha.
Oh, he's just a regular guy.
Proper ammo.
Ammo shot two times or less.
Intact trophy organs.
Hit one.
Yeah, I don't need you.
Better money though.
Really?
But like...
How do I get more money?
Do I just like press enter and then I get more money from him?
Oh, I just keep harvest?
Just harvest him?
Okay.
Alright.
Goodbye, wolf.
Alright, now I can go back.
Alright, see guys?
I told you I can hunt.
Look at that.
Now I sent a message to all my nature reserve animals.
Pay your rent or you are gonna get taxidermied.
I have a friend.
Okay.
I don't know why, but like for some reason I have like multiple friends that are really into rat taxidermy.
But like they don't do the taxidermy.
Okay, have you guys ever seen like those little rat figures?
The taxidermy rat figures?
And they're in like these funny poses.
So I have more than one friend that's like super into that and has like an actual like mini mini collection of them.
And they're both artists.
I don't know if that's like an artist thing.
They like buy it from like Etsy sellers.
No, have you ever seen those tax taxidermy rats on Etsy?
Where they're like they like dress them up in like funny poses and scenarios.
And you can like, and then I remember watching like cold ones and like you can commission them to like make like make OCs of yourself.
So you can make like technically make a Doki bird rat and like have them dressed up as me.
I was watching cold ones and like they like they commissioned someone they commissioned one of those Etsy sellers to make one of them.
That's kind...
The most prized Doki shrine figure.
A taxidermy Doki rat.
Yeah, I'm here now.
Yeah.
I'm gonna keep the doors open.
I want the bear to come in and grab me.
I want a real fight.
I was like no, the bear's gonna come.
What the fuck is that bear gonna do?
All I have in there are my guns.
That's it.
Like is he gonna come in there and fucking steal a gun and then shoot me?
Like I like to see him try.
Well, you aren't wrong.
Some of us artists really like rats.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is he just gonna come into my house and sleep in my bed?
That's good!
It's easier for me to kill him.
I'm gonna keep the door open.
Oh, it'll pass time and restore my...
Yeah, you know what?
Oh, I need pay?
How much is it?
No, I don't need to pay.
Fuck that.
Alright.
Oh, he's like guarding me.
Oh, that's sweet.
Alright, I have to...
pick up a backpack.
Oh, is the backpack inside the house?
It's in here?
Where's the backpack?
Where is it?
Storage?
The fuck is the backpack?
Oh, the table?
Oh, there it is.
Sorry.
I thought it was like a regular backpack.
That just looks like a fanny pack.
Alright, I'll go get to the fallen tree.
I might as well just rent a B&B.
If it's like $2.50 at this like...
There's no heating here!
Might as well go fucking find an Air B&B around this nature reserve.
Guys...
Although I'm the landlord, I don't pay rent.
I make people pay my rent.
I'm just gonna run.
I don't think there's animals near me.
I don't hear no warning call.
I should be fine.
There's no warning calls around me.
Is there anything around here?
Wait.
No, that's just a tree.
Alright.
Okay.
How do I know if it...
No, it's my timeshare, guys.
I pay...
I own this property.
This is my timeshare.
This is my month, guys.
For me to be here on this nature reserve.
I pay...
$800 a year.
So I can come here...
During my timeshare moments.
So I come here...
Once every five years.
To do my hunting.
Of squatters.
Guys...
You're spending your month...
Marking trees.
Did I mark it?
Am I done?
Mark trees near the infested area for investigation.
Which trees?
This one?
This tree?
Oh, yeah.
This tree.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what timeshares are.
You co-own the area.
And you come over there once every five years.
I thought it was quite...
And I got like...
A voucher and like...
A free continental breakfast during the presentation.
Wait.
There was an animal crying at me.
What a bargain.
Thanks for taking care of this.
It's becoming a full on phobia of mine.
I'm using my timeshare to mark trees.
Oh, nice.
I got more money.
Okay,
that's good because I heard an animal right here too.
Alright, yeah.
No problem.
Why is he so scared of them?
Their music isn't that bad.
And he just needs to wait five more years for the last one to die.
They'll be gone forever.
Okay.
Very odd.
Oh, it's a mating call.
Oh, it killed a mother.
That's ruined the special time.
I'll give them a nice surprise.
Where is he?
Where is the mating?
I'm getting my binoculars out for it.
Where are you guys?
I heard the call.
Oh.
Oh, there's the call.
Don't worry.
You're calling for somebody else to come over.
I got my binoculars out for the special occasion.
Alright.
Let the pros score.
I'm just, I'm just, you know.
I'm gonna make sure they'll get it, you know.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll watch from an adequate distance away.
Look, we need to populate.
It's just like pandas, okay?
I'm trying to make sure.
I'm trying to make sure our nature reserve does not run out of out of foxes.
Just creeping up.
Very slowly.
He can't run.
He can't.
Come on.
He's gotta be close, right?
Where is he?
I'm slowly heading over.
I know you're still trying to find it.
Okay.
Let's walk a little closer.
Can't be that bad.
Where is he?
You see any of them?
Oh, he's 110.
Oh, he traveled further away.
He hasn't found him yet.
He hasn't found one yet.
He's still looking.
Someone please swipe.
Was it right or left?
I'm gonna die.
Please, someone answer his call.
He's desperate.
Someone match him.
Match his profile.
Swipe right.
He's desperate.
He's been calling for 20 years.
You up?
He's like, you up?
Anyone?
Where the fuck is he?
Come on, call again.
I don't see any of them.
Come on.
I brought these binoculars for nothing.
No!
Where did he go?
He didn't even leave.
Oh my god.
He ran.
Now I bought these binoculars for nothing.
How was I supposed to know?
I didn't even see him.
Where could he have ran to?
Where could he have even ran to?
Okay.
There's not even... Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Wait,
not the wrong gun.
Okay, do you think I can hit the shot?
Wait, how do I make...
Okay.
Alright.
Do you think I can hit the shot?
Okay.
Guys, do you think I hit him?
Guys, do you think?
Do you think I...
I don't die!
What is my win?!
Guys, I don't think I hit him.
I don't think.
He like...
He didn't even fucking move.
I was like, did I do it?
And he like lagged out or some shit.
Nice, okay.
Go look for blood, I guess.
No, that's alright.
I don't think there's blood anywhere.
This doesn't seem like there's blood.
I have to look at tree branches for win?
I thought you were telling me.
I thought it would be like a win meeting.
I mean, it doesn't look like there's win.
Alright.
Well, I'm not going back for that caribou.
That's fine.
I'll go...
Come on.
Come on, dad.
Let's go find a bear.
Yeah, my heart rate was too high.
I think I was shaking or some shit.
I was most likely just running too much.
Alright, let's go back.
And there's bullet drops too.
I should've aimed it higher.
That's fine.
I'm so sad.
I brought these binoculars, so...
Damn it.
He heard me?
Why did he hear me?
I'm so far away.
I don't even know where he is.
Alright, let's just go.
That's fine if he heard me.
Just run.
Go and make more babies.
I'll hunt your kids.
You think I care?
I'll just get your kids.
No, it was another caribou.
Can I see if there's any just roaming in the open plains?
Oh, he went that way.
Run, forest, run.
I mean, at least I saw...
I know he exists now.
There's like so little animals here.
I feel like...
Is it us?
Is it because of me?
What a wild sentence.
All I'm saying...
Is that...
Is that I'm patient.
I can wait.
Your kids might not be as fast as you.
I'll just end your bloodline.
Oh, he's mating too.
There he is.
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
Okay, I got this.
Did I get him?
Guys, it says fleeing...
But do you think I got him?
I looked at bullet drops.
But...
But what about...
How do I track him?
Wait, how do you track him anyway?
Okay.
Because I looked at the...
Oh, it's over here.
The wind is so...
I mean, it doesn't look like there's big wind.
See?
Look for blood?
Okay.
I'll go look.
He can't run too far, right?
Very old.
God damn it.
Someone's gotta clean this poop.
I think that's him.
Oh, he fled.
God damn it, that was him.
I didn't see him.
Okay, I'm gonna track.
Look for blood or footprints.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Oh, he ran that way.
I'm coming back.
I'm gonna end your bloodline right here.
Did he go this way?
Where did he go?
I can't tell where he ran.
Here?
There's so many tracks.
Which one's the right one?
Okay, he ate here.
He walked over here.
And then he started eating.
And then, where did he go?
Here.
That's where he fled to.
Oh, there's ducks.
Oh, I have skill points?
Very fresh.
Okay, he's somewhere here.
He still wants to...
Don't worry.
He still wants to bang.
Wait, where does it...
It says nothing.
Alright.
Oh, it's over here.
I'm gonna get you.
Can't run away from me.
Don't worry.
I'm here to end your bloodline.
Right here.
The other ones.
The other ones, I'll kill the children.
You, I'll kill you now.
I'm patient.
I'm patient enough.
Alright.
He's just trotting?
He's not even running.
You smell him, dad?
You smell him?
Where is he?
Okay, he's very...
Bro, what the fuck?
Stop pooping!
You're ruining my environment!
Alright, okay.
So, like, apparently, dog poop is, like, really, really bad.
For the environment.
So, what's the difference between, like, dog poop and, like, deer poop, caribou poop?
We, like, poop twice.
Three times.
Wait, very old?
Wait a minute, am I not tracking the right...
Same one?
Oh, it's what we feed them.
Okay.
Like, is this the same...
How many caribou lives here?
Organic free range.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's a lot of them.
Wait, okay, I'm pivoting, guys.
Wait, unless...
Unless the caribou is right here.
Oh, so dogs can't, like, fertilize.
Okay, never mind.
You can poop as much as you want.
Never mind.
It's healthier.
Oh, so dog poop is, like, toxic waste.
Okay.
I get it.
Wait, is that him?
I saw him right over...
No.
Wait, is that?
I can't tell.
I'm just following a bunch of fucking poop and prints.
Oh, I see him.
I see him, he's right over there.
I see him.
He's right there.
Where's my binoculars?
Which one is it?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
He doesn't know.
Okay, I can do this.
Shh.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
Let's go, let's go!
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
That was a shot!
Wait, where did I hit him?
Where did I hit him?
Let's fucking go!
I told you!
I'll end your fucking bloodline!
Okay.
You're fine.
The blood.
Where's the blood?
Just now.
Oh!
Oh, I see the blood!
I'm coming for you!
You're fucking pooping your skin!
You can't run forever!
The more you run, the more blood you lose!
Just keep running!
Keep running!
Okay.
Where are you?
Oh, wait.
Blood rate very low.
God damn it.
Okay, we're just gonna look.
He's like somewhere here.
He's fleeing.
Okay, it's right here.
Okay.
I'm gonna stop running.
Blood rate very low.
He's somewhere here.
I know you're here, little guy.
I know you're here.
You're still bleeding.
Where are you?
It looks like you're still bleeding.
Oh.
Where are you?
Wait, that's not what I wanted.
Where the fuck is the blood?
Oh, look.
There's more blood.
Oh, you can't bleed forever.
Alright, it's over here.
Don't worry, I'm still following.
I'm still following.
Where did you run to?
I'll always find you.
Wait.
Where did the track go?
Oh, it's over here.
It's over here.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute, the track stopped.
Don't worry.
I can still find you.
Oh, you're gone now.
Oh, very fresh.
Oh.
Don't worry, I see your tracks.
I see it.
Let me just slowly walk up to you.
Where is he?
He's here somewhere.
He's here.
Goddammit, that's him!
That's him, that's him too.
Goddammit!
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm still gonna... You think you can run?
You think you can run?
You're lucky.
You're so lucky that you saw me there, but you're still bleeding.
You'll eventually lose too much blood.
You can keep running.
You'll eventually lose too much and you gotta slow down.
Can't run that far from me.
Don't worry, I still got your trail.
I still got it.
Alright, how do you lay down?
I only know how to crouch.
I hear you.
I know you're here somewhere.
Oh, I know you're here.
I heard you trotting along.
Think you're safe?
You think you're safe, little guy?
Oh, you're so bleeding.
Don't worry.
One day, you're gonna lose all your blood.
It's alright.
Don't worry, I'm here to end your suffering.
Oh, you just ran?
Just gonna keep running?
You're just gonna keep running?
Where did these tracks go?
Okay, he walked back and then he walked back and forth.
Fuck, okay, wait.
Oh, it's in front of me, okay.
There's more blood here.
He thinks he can get away, but I'm patient.
I'm very patient.
I have the adrenaline running in.
I hit that first shot.
I hit that shot.
And then...
And now I'm never leaving.
I'm never leaving you.
You think I'll...
You think I'm gonna give up now?
Oh, I hit that first shot, little guy.
I hit that first shot, I'm never leaving.
I'm making sure you're going...
You're gonna be nice.
You're gonna be a nice display in my home before the bears get you.
Got a family to feed.
Oh, you're trotting back and forth trying to lose me?
Oh, I know you're just walking over here.
Fuck, he saw me.
There he is.
I see you.
Oh, I know where you are.
You're gonna keep running?
Oh, you're gonna keep running?
That's cute.
That's so cute.
I know you went this way.
I saw where you ran.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, he's smart.
He's smart.
He's very smart.
Wait.
Oh, these tracks.
He went that way?
But then he went backwards.
Wait.
Wait, I lost the tracks.
Guys.
I actually...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Guys, we have a problem now.
Wait.
He actually...
Wait, I think he juked me, guys.
He went up the trees.
Wait a minute.
Guys, he might have actually... Like, he went that way, and then he like... Where did he go?
Where did he...
Wait.
Wait, the fuck is this?
Bro,
the tracks stopped there.
That doesn't make sense.
Wait, the tracks actually stopped.
Where did it go?
Wait.
Left?
This side?
Okay.
We're checking the map.
Look, it actually stopped right here.
It disappeared.
He walked this way.
And then he walked that way.
And then he walked back here.
Wait a minute.
All the tracks stopped.
Look.
I don't know.
Okay, I might need you to...
I might need a track for me.
I don't know, man.
He's not Bloodhound, so I don't know.
He grew wings and flew.
Like, where did he go?
He actually disappeared.
There's no more blue tracks anywhere.
How did he juke me?
He actually juked me.
This fucker.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
That was such a good shot, too.
He actually got away.
I can't fucking believe it.
Oh my God, I'm so sad.
I worked so hard tracking this, too.
Did he walk backwards?
There's no way he walked...
No, he didn't!
See, he walked forward here, and then, like, the blood splatter's here.
You know what?
I'm gonna kill a bear.
Kill a bear.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Alright.
I'm gonna kill a bear instead, I guess.
Yeah, fuck it.
I don't care.
Wait, it's two bears.
I don't think I hit it.
Leveled up.
It's fine.
I'm mad.
I'm just mad.
I can't believe he actually got away.
Oh my God, I'm so mad.
I can't believe he successfully got away.
Oh, I was so into this hunt, too.
Oh, the bear family.
Like, he literally his tracks disappeared.
Like, there's no other tracks, too.
He actually juked me.
This fucking stupid-ass deer successfully got away.
I worked so fucking... Like, there's no more blue tracks anywhere.
There's no more.
The tracks stopped.
Like, how is that possible?
How is...
How is... It's gone!
It's actually gone!
Like...
Successfully evaded taxes.
Like, where did it go?
Smart deer.
I'm so sad.
I was such a good shot, too.
I can't believe it.
There's no more blue anywhere.
Like, it climbed up a tree?
Clever deer.
A Christmas miracle happened today, guys.
The second caribou fucking grew wings and flew off.
He lived another day.
I can't believe.
I can't believe he actually lived, dad.
I can't fucking believe it.
He learned how to climb a tree.
I knew reindeers could fly.
I don't... I don't understand!
Wait, is that his tracks?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I found you.
I found you in the end.
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
I found you.
We're back, boys.
We're looking back.
Oh my god.
He knows it's feeding time.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta feed him.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna kill this fucking deer if it's the last thing I do.
This is my entire...
I swear to god.
I swear to god, I need this deer dead.
Everything I've been through.
Okay, where did the tracks go?
Wait.
Where did the tracks go after that?
Wait, the tracks are gone again.
What the fuck?
How did the tracks disappear again?
Oh my god.
This is a new deer.
This is not even the same deer.
This is a different deer.
Oh my god.
I'll never find this stupid ass deer.
Oh wait, it's fresh poop.
I'll never find this stupid fucking deer.
Okay, but this is fresh poop though.
Okay, this is a resting zone.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Is there anybody sipping water?
There's no water sippers here.
Okay, no water sippers.
Oh my god, there was a deer here.
But like, I don't see any animals around me.
There's nobody vocalizing.
God damn it.
God fucking damn it.
We were so close.
It disappeared.
He actually like grew wings or something.
He fucking climbed a tree.
I don't know.
He climbed a tree and flew away.
The stupid fucking deer.
The deer friends will never... He drank Red Bull.
Maybe there's some of them in the water.
No, but his tracks disappeared.
How do I...
How do I spend my skill point?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I have zero skill point.
I don't even have skill point.
I can't believe it.
He lived to tell the tale.
Now all his deer friends are gonna think he's so cool.
I can't fucking believe it.
I have one?
Wait, do I?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Alright, we wanna... I have to... Okay, I have to buy this.
Alright, now I'm a better tracker.
I got this gunshot in the war.
Got to go here.
There's like nothing around me.
Why does no one wanna be in the open?
Wait, there's new deer.
What is this?
There's new deer.
Alright, new target.
New target.
I'll grab this new deer if it's the... I will kill a deer.
I will end somebody's bloodline today.
Okay?
Somebody's bloodline has to end.
If it's the last thing I do.
I'm going to create Bambi.
I...
I need to make sure Bambi happens guys.
Alright, this way.
Okay, there's a deer over there.
I'm falling deer.
The wolves don't count.
I wanna make sure Bambi becomes canon.
Walked here, but...
Oh, there's another tracks here.
Alright, we go this way.
I don't think we're killing a bear, guys.
I don't think we're getting any bear kills.
I don't understand.
They're clearly here in the open.
They were, but now they're not.
Poop ends here.
Why does the poop end here?
Did he fucking fly too?
Oh no, it's over there.
Okay, I was gonna say, where the fuck did the rest of them go?
Alright, I figured it out.
I'm also gonna grab a water sample too.
Oh, it's not this water.
Okay, there's more poop here.
Jesus Christ, they poop like every 10 seconds.
They have too much fiber in their diets.
Wait, the poop... Oh no, the poop doesn't end here.
What happens if I walk into the lake?
Huh?
Dad walked into the lake and he's fine.
Look at him.
He doesn't do much for me, but he's fine.
Alright.
More poop.
Wait, the poop trail end.
Wait, the poop trail ended.
Wait a minute.
I swear to fucking oh my...
I walked back because the poop trail ended and then he runs away.
Like, I don't understand.
His poop trail ended.
There's nothing left.
There's nothing.
His other tracker's gone.
How many deer's are here?
Okay.
Alright, fuck this.
Fuck this.
I'm going to my other quest.
Fuck these deer's.
I'll kill another deer.
There's plenty of deer's around here.
These deer's are...
These deer's are... Anyway, fuck this.
Another deer will show up and they'll be over.
I believe.
It doesn't matter.
A deer will eventually show his face around here.
There's plenty of deer's in the sea for me to hunt.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we gotta grab water here.
Are there any secret deer's hiding here?
Does no one want to drink a water in this beautiful lake?
Alright, I got my water sample.
Oh my god, don't worry.
I know where there's plenty of animal shit.
Don't worry!
I have plenty of poop for you to fucking examine.
Wait, I'm a bit lost.
Where am I?
I don't even know where I am anymore.
I don't even know.
Like, where am I?
What is that?
There's not even tracks anywhere.
I'm so lost.
How do they know I'm here?
I'm a deer country.
Wait, how is there no more poop?
There's so many poop and now there's no more?
Where the fuck did they all go?
What happened to the caribou population?
They moved out?
How did the entire population of caribou just disappear?
Like, did they like mine themselves out?
Oh my god, it's like the Mayans.
The greatest mystery of all time.
There's some poop.
They all got ratchet.
Here, I got it.
Alright.
I'm tracking like four different caribou poops apparently.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't understand why all these things just disappear.
There's more tracks here.
I always hear ducks but like, where are these ducks?
Oh my god, they were above me this entire time.
Watch this.
Oh, hit the shot.
Okay, but would it be wild if I could actually hit that?
Like, wouldn't that be fucking wild though?
It was worth the try.
But it would be so cool if I hit them!
Guys, it would have looked so fucking cool if I did hit that shot.
It's just up top.
Don't they have to come down and like, you know...
Like, drink water?
I lost the tracks.
There's like so much poop but yet like, zero fucking caribou.
Okay, eventually I'll hit that shot and it'll be so cool.
Oh boy.
Okay, but when I do hit that shot, guys...
It would happen, guys.
It would happen and it would look so fucking cool.
And then you guys would clip it and it'll go viral and be like, oh my god, VTuber hits the nastiest shot of her life.
Guys...
There's like nothing over here.
Alright, let's head...
Let's head back to Lumber Shore.
Wait, where's home?
Where is home?
Oh my god, I traveled so fucking far.
The shot that ended the hunt, exactly.
God, can it stop snowing in Alaska?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
I thought I saw something move.
Something not move over there?
I'm going crazy.
This hunt is making me go crazy.
I swear to god, I thought I saw something move over there.
Oh my...
I'm not okay anymore.
I'm...
I'm losing it.
I'm losing it, guys.
Ever since that deer that fucking flew away, I can't...
I don't know where I am anymore.
I...
Mental, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nice to see more creators playing this game.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, he's close.
Don't worry, I got the shotgun.
Oh, he's gonna start making babies.
Where are you?
Baby makers.
It would be so cool if I hit the shot, though.
Guys, I know that...
It would be so cool if I hit the shot, though, guys.
Okay.
Alright, let me get closer.
Let me get closer.
He won't know.
Is this close enough, guys?
Here's the win.
No, no, no!
No!
Guys, do you think I hit it?
Guys, do you think I hit the shot?
Do you think I hit it?
It'd be so cool if I did here.
No, but it'd be so cool though!
Guys, guys, look.
I know, but it'd be so cool if...
Look, it would have been really cool if it did work out.
Guys, it's all about the gamble.
It's all about the gamble, alright?
We're here to make flashy plays, yeah, alright?
We're here to be flashy.
Okay, but if the rifle hits that bird...
Hits a bird in a piercing shot, it would have been so fucking cool.
It's the thrill, guys.
It's the thrill.
I'm not throwing.
I'm just trying to make a cool shot.
That's different.
It's different, guys.
Oh, wait.
It has to fall down, right?
What comes up, must come down.
Come on.
Okay, but if I did hit that shot, it would have been so fucking cool.
And you know it.
Yeah, they're traveling.
Where are they traveling to?
Where are you guys flying to?
You have to come down sooner or later.
You guys stay up there forever.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, no, that's nothing.
I'm just seeing things now.
I'm just seeing things.
I'm never gonna find another deer.
They're going back to Canada.
Alright, we go this way.
There has to be.
There has to be another deer somewhere.
I will fucking kill.
I need to end somebody's bloodline.
Come on.
How can I end a bloodline if they don't show up?
I send letters and everything.
I'll be like, come here if you want your bloodline ended.
Free of charge.
There's not even tracks anywhere.
I've lost all tracks.
Do you think they heard my gunshots?
Could it be all the gunshots I've been shooting?
All the shots I've been shooting from my rifle?
Do you think it's that, guys?
Please, I have a family to feed.
My dragoons are gonna starve.
Whoops.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over very slowly.
I hear him.
Don't worry, I'm here to feed you guys.
There he is.
I don't know where he is, but there he is.
He...
I'm very slowly getting there.
Guys, please.
You can start for five more minutes.
If you can start for like an hour, you can start for five more minutes.
I...
Wait,
the bullets are not effect... Why did you tell me there's wind and bullet drop?
I was literally aiming intentionally for like bullet drop and wind.
Oh my god.
I can't believe... Oh my god.
I literally... I was literally aiming intentionally as if there was a bullet drop and oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Wait, where did the moose go?
Oh my god, your wife's gonna call me now?
Hey there, this is Sani.
Can you take the shot and send it to me?
No.
Wait, the moose is gone.
Where did the moose go?
Where the fuck did the moose go?
Oh my god.
Okay, I shouldn't have fucking crawled.
I should've just walked.
The moose disappeared.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
The moose fucking disappeared.
The moose also disappeared.
Oh my god, they all just keep disappearing.
They all...
He's over here somewhere.
Where is he?
Bro, okay, lay down.
Lay down.
He's like, what are you doing?
Bro, apparently you gotta lay down.
Okay.
Okay, be very quiet.
We're hunting moose now.
He's just like, what are you doing?
I'm trying to find the fucking moose.
I need a... Okay, we are ending somebody's bloodline before I fucking kill something for real.
Alright, there's no way.
Oh, he gave a warning call.
He's here somewhere.
I need to end somebody's bloodline.
Like, somebody's bloodline will end some way or another.
He was here.
He was warning me.
He was like, do not approach.
Do you see him?
I don't see any fucking moose anywhere.
Like, I'm just crawling.
Where the fuck is this stupid fucking moose?
Where?
Oh my god, he's here.
Okay.
What?
Okay, there we go.
I hit him.
Okay, there's fine.
I did it.
I hit him.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I hit him.
That's all that matters.
He's over there.
Alright, let's go.
That's fine.
I know where you... I saw where you ran at.
You're like here somewhere.
Alright.
God, it's very low again.
It's a very low bloodshot too.
That's the worst part.
Alright.
Okay.
I'll just shoot multiple times.
Like, I'll make it work.
Where did he go?
I swear to fucking god.
I swear to god.
If he fucking disappears.
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Oh my...
Where did he go?
That's the same guy.
That has to be the same guy.
That has to be the same moose.
There's no way.
That has to be him.
I don't know what the fuck happened to the other trail, but like...
Oh
my...
What happened to my trail?
Like, what happened?
What happened to my tracker?
Like, I don't understand.
It actually disappeared again.
I should have bought the bloodhound.
Why did I bring a golden retriever?
I should have just...
Oh my god.
I lost the tracks again.
Like, I look here and then there's no more blue trails.
Like, what do you mean?
Like, he ran this way and then the trail disappears.
Oh my god, there it is.
I found it.
I found the stupid fucking trail.
Oh my gosh.
He ran this way.
Then where did he go?
Oh, he went this way.
Okay.
Alright, we figured it out, guys.
Oh no, he's gonna fucking disappear again.
I can feel it.
Okay, it's a mother and a child.
So like...
Alright, we got this.
Okay, we'll shoot the lungs.
Okay, but I did hit a shot 200 meters away, guys.
Come on.
Is that not brag-worthy right there?
Did he fucking disappear again?
No, it's over here.
Okay, I need to wait for another...
No!
Okay, he ran because he heard me here when I was trying to fucking find his tracks.
Alright.
I hope I hit the child.
If it was a child, because it might be easier to kill.
It's this way.
Alright, very low.
Oh my god, their blood is so low.
Okay, to be fair, I was sort of trying to aim for the head, but then I realized it might not have worked.
I was trying to aim for the head there.
Moose is close by.
Where the fuck is this moose?
Did he really run that far?
Like, where...
No!
There they are, there they are, there they are, there they are.
There he is.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, I swear to god, lie down.
I swear to god.
Lay down.
I swear to god, if this moose fucking runs away again, I swear to fucking god, I...
I don't see him, that's the worst part.
I don't know where he is.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Where is he?
He literally looked at me.
Where did he go?
He just walked away?
Okay, I don't...
Go and do your mating shit, I'm trying to find a moose right now.
Bro, he just walked away.
How
far could you walk away?
There's no cover.
There's no cover whatsoever.
He just walked away.
Yes, I killed like two wolves.
And that was it.
That was it.
That was the end of my journey.
I'm bleeding.
ARE YOU FUCKING
KIDDING...
Goodbye.
Good fucking bye, I guess.
Okay, very old.
Okay, he's been here a very long time ago.
Guys, the trail ended here.
Guys.
Oh thank god, there's... Nevermind, I found it.
I found it.
We'll find this stupid ass moose somewhere.
Oh my god.
Okay, he came back.
Alright.
We're gonna find this stupid moose somewhere.
I can't believe I didn't get the baby.
The baby would have been easier.
He ran?
When?
I wasn't...
This is it.
They won't walk away.
There's so many of them.
Oh my god.
This is the motherlode.
I'm gonna slowly get over it.
There's no way by the time I get there, they would be dead.
This is the motherlode.
This time.
Oh my...
Oh, I have to prone that.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Oh my god, I keep accidentally proning.
I'm sorry.
This is the motherlode.
This is the actual...
Alright.
There's no way they see me.
I'm gonna go to the side.
Let's just do this.
Okay, you stay here.
Okay.
They know.
No, they don't.
They didn't see me.
They don't see me, guys.
No, they didn't.
They were just giving warning calls.
They don't see me.
No, guys.
Shh.
They don't see me, guys.
They're just warning.
No, they're still there.
They're still there.
I swear to god.
I'm gonna pop up from underneath the tree.
And then...
I swear to god.
Stay down.
They don't see me, guys.
I'm gonna pop up from underneath this tree.
And then I'm gonna see all of the family.
No, no, no.
They're not done drinking.
They're gonna be there.
I swear to god.
The moment I pop up from this grass, I'm gonna see the family.
They're gonna be right there.
The moment the grass is gone.
It's gonna be right there.
Right here.
The moment the grass is...
The moment I get past all this grass.
I will see them.
Right here.
Right now.
Where am I in this pile of grass?
Wait, how do I see anything from here?
Right here.
Right now.
They're gonna be over there.
Where am I?
Right here.
Right now.
Where's the lake?
Am I like...
Okay.
They're right there.
No, they're still there.
Guys, guys, guys.
Almost there.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Okay, where is it from?
Okay.
They're still there.
They're actually still there.
Holy fuck.
I had to...
I didn't believe for a second.
But they're still there.
They're actually still there.
Okay, I had to get up to double check.
I had to...
I had to double check if they're still there.
Alright.
Is this the lungs?
Right here?
Is that the lungs?
If I shoot here, will I hit the lungs?
If I shoot here, will I hit the lungs, guys?
Right here.
I'm so sad.
I'm so...
You guys said there's no bullet drop!
Is there?
Oh my god!
Wait.
They don't die.
I swear to god.
He's too slow.
I swear to god there's a...
Get out.
Are you still alive?
Bro!
What the fuck?!
Do it to me!
Bro!
This won't take...
My
god!
You just let him do that to me?!
This won't live!
I don't understand!
Oh my god!
He was too angry to die.
Okay, what kills...
Okay.
What?
Fuck.
I'm too broke, guys.
All I have is the free gun.
I don't have anything else.
I only have the free gun.
I don't understand!
This won't live so long.
Oh my god.
He's a tracker, not a...
He has a very realistic...
I shot him four times!
I don't understand!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're using the wrong caliber ammo for moves that are like...
That are not...
Like, if you open your map after...
You'll see purple on the map.
If you killed it, indicating hunter pressure.
Oh, like here?
It's purple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who will win?
A noob with a .22 pistol?
Or a tank wolf?
Me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe...
It fucking lived for so long.
Oh, hunter...
Win pressure.
Mid pressure, mid pressure.
I can't believe...
Who healed him?
That wolf was the tankiest fucking shit ever!
Who the fuck healed this stupid fucking wolf?
I...
Thank you, killed.
Did I?
Did I kill him?
I don't fucking know where I killed him.
When did I...
When did I shot a thing here?
It was a paladin build, he healed himself.
Oh my god, thank god he...
This fucker bleed out.
Fuck that wolf.
Why didn't I have a dead zone here?
What happened here?
Cause I know I killed something.
What the fuck happened here?
Let's check the purple zone.
Okay, I'm gonna be in the purple zone.
I'm just gonna run.
Maybe I'll find a fucking dead moose here.
Alright, we're almost at the purple zone.
He put me in a stupid fucking highlight reel.
Alright.
Almost there.
There's a bison?!
Oh, he saw me.
Wait, but it's a purple zone.
You're gunning and killing that?
Oh, okay.
Those are protected animals.
Yeah, in my nature reserve.
I put them there for me to hunt.
Hey, but somebody said the moose died.
Where the fuck did the moose die?
What can my gun kill at this point?
Can I even kill a deer?
Like, what can I kill?
Oh, rat birds.
Oh my god, I'm not going back to the...
Guys, what about caribous?
Can I kill caribous?
Probably not.
So I've been hunting that caribou for no fucking reason.
Okay.
Alright, I'm leaving Alaska.
Oh my god, there's no deer here!
Everything here is just caribous, moose, and like a wolf.
And I found a bison too.
Guys, I'm at the...
Wait, there's a red fox.
Okay.
Wait, I can cut down the fox.
Wait, I can hunt kill foxes though.
Wait, I might be able to kill a fox though.
Alright.
He pooped somewhere near here.
Alright, next mission.
A fucking fox.
Okay, he's been trotting.
Wait, hover over the ammo and it'll show you?
Okay.
How do I hover my ammo?
Here?
How do I do it?
Whatever.
Don't worry, I will kill something.
Guys, the only thing I've killed here were the fucking...
Oh, where's the ammo tab?
Oh, ammo!
I can kill...
Okay, you liars!
I can kill a caribou!
Yeah!
Oh my god, I could've killed a caribou.
That's a caribou!
Okay, it's very old.
Okay, he might be gone-gone.
Okay, so it's just...
Look, it's not a skill issue.
I just...
He like climbed a tree or something.
Guys.
He fucking climbed a tree.
Like, what was I supposed to do?
Like...
He climbed a tree and flew away.
Okay.
Took you for like the past half hour.
Okay, do they or do they not have bullet drop?
Like, please.
I've been going in.
I can't...
Like, I'm getting like...
Look, I have to adjust my gun.
I need to know.
Do they or...
Okay, no, do they not?
And then yes, and then...
Guys, like...
How I aim is affected by whether or not there is bullet drop.
Yes.
No.
I don't know what's a lie.
Like, I don't know either!
Is there wind?
Yes,
they do not.
Alright.
Bullet drop is when the bullet starts dropping.
Bro, fuck this.
I'm not gonna find anything around me.
Oh my god!
Okay, there was some...
Oh, now there's something over there.
God fucking damn it.
Oh my god.
Hunting is so hard.
Hunting is so hard, guys.
Who would've thought?
Hunting was so difficult.
Okay, there's tracks.
Okay.
I have tracks on me.
This is where he fled, right?
Okay, red zone.
He went this way.
Okay.
What is over there?
Is this where he's resting?
Is this maybe where he's resting?
Dad?
Think he's still there?
Sleeping?
I'll be so fucked up if I just find one of them just sleeping there and I just take the shot right there.
Do I just go like...
I'm not desperate enough to do that.
And then I miss.
And then I fucking miss.
You know what?
No, you're right.
No, you're fucking right.
I see him resting and I fucking miss right here.
Point blank.
I shoot and I missed and I missed again and I shot my gun and I missed.
This is the entire stream.
Okay.
He's trotting, he's not scared.
Might be close.
He can't run away far.
Come on.
Come on, little guy.
Come on, you must not have ran far, right?
Guys, if I knew my equipment affects this so much, I would have paid to win.
I would have paid to win if I knew.
If I knew these guns are fucking dog shit, unless I paid, I would have.
Okay.
Is she on the Alaska map with the .243?
I just wanted to fucking be in Canada.
I didn't know the starting gun fucking sucks in Alaska.
I just wanted to be and then they still put me in Alaska.
Okay.
I'm not even in Canada, that's the worst.
I literally bought this map because I wanted to be in Canada.
This was designed for ending.
God damn it!
That's it, I'm leaving Canada.
Fuck this.
Okay.
I'm leaving Canada.
I'm running.
I'm straight up running.
You can't run forever.
I'll find what you look like.
Oh, it's very fresh.
I know you're close.
I'm going to fucking get you.
What the fuck?
Okay, I know I can't kill you.
I'm leaving.
I know I can't kill you.
Can I at least kill...
Oh, I can't kill a bear.
There's no way I can kill a bear.
I'm going to find where you live, fox.
You're in the open now.
Where is he?
You're in the open.
Where are you?
Okay, lay down.
You sit down.
He's somewhere close by.
I know it.
Alright.
He has to be close by.
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe he's not close.
Come on, little guy.
Why is it taking so long to find one?
I'm trying my best, okay?
Okay, guys.
I am trying my absolute best.
It's not my fault that they keep disappearing.
It's not my fault.
You must be around here.
You can't walk forever.
You must be.
There's no way you can disappear again.
I swear to fucking God.
One of you has to show up.
Very fresh.
Very fresh poop right here.
Very, very fresh.
That means you're here.
You're very close by.
Oh my God, you're so close by.
Where are you, little guy?
Where are you?
Come on, come on.
You went this way.
Can't walk forever, little guy.
Come out, come out.
Where the fuck did the tracks go?
You poop again for me real quick?
Where the fuck?
Like, do you see anything?
I don't.
Where the fuck did this trail go?
Okay, we can't deal with the moose, so...
Wait, it's gone!
What the fuck?
Where did it go?
Did he also start climbing?
Did he also grow wings?
Where the fuck did the tracks go?
Oh my God, it's over here.
I think he walked this way too far.
He's gonna run.
He's gonna fucking run now.
He's just casually trotting along.
He's gonna see me before I see him and then he's gonna fucking run away.
Like a little bitch that he is.
What the fuck is this stupid fox, you whore?
You had to pay rent.
You're three months behind.
There's another track here?
Wait, there's two fox tracks.
No, that's a deer.
Okay, it's fresh, but not very fresh.
So he's not as close by.
Wait, no, those are white tracks.
Where did the blue tracks go?
Oh my God, where did the blue tracks go?
He pooped and he climbed.
I don't fucking know.
Okay, there it is.
I was gonna say, did he poop and start climbing again?
He might be at the lake.
Oh my God.
He could be drinking water.
Wait, there's hope.
I don't see anything.
Where could this stupid fucking fox walk if it said fresh poop?
I don't understand.
How fresh is this poop?
Oh my God, you fucker.
Okay, he's...
I thought he was gonna scare someone away.
He's still just trotting somewhere.
Wherever he is.
Wherever he's fucking trotting along.
He's still...
I've been following this trail for 80 years.
This is like my Moby Dick story.
I'm here to fucking kill Moby Dick.
I'm gonna be hunting for this fox for 20 fucking years.
No, I can't hear my voice.
I don't have open mic, I'm pretty sure.
Like, the worst part is I've never seen the fox before, but he's seen me.
He's seen me multiple times.
I don't
even...
Oh, it can smell me?
Okay, but I have this.
Oh wait, that's my deer call.
I thought...
I thought that was something else.
Wait, it made a sound.
It was like...
Was that him?
That has to be the fox call.
It was like...
Where
is he?
I don't know what he looks like.
There's
no way!
What happened to my scope?
Was that my shotgun?
Oh my god, dude.
He's bleeding.
He's fucking bleeding.
I'm fucking...
Wait, I downed him with an unscoped?
No, I didn't miss.
I didn't miss.
She's bleeding.
He's actually bleeding.
Oh, he's dead.
I did it.
I could have followed you for 80 years!
Or could I have killed you?
I did it!
Oh my god!
I did something!
No one else got...
Broke his fucking leg.
We got him!
We fucking got him!
Broke your legs!
That's fine.
I don't care that it's a prize.
I'm fine.
As long as I broke his legs.
I think that's okay.
What happened to my scope?
My scope...
My scope is gone.
I've got a taxidermy.
Yes!
But also, what happened to my scope?
It's gone.
I didn't...
I don't know what gun I was using at that...
No, it was actually...
Oh, I accidentally clicked on...
I was so...
I was so confused.
I didn't...
I was like...
What happened to my scope?
I was trying to kill him.
Okay.
Alright, we got him.
Okay, I'm...
Okay, how do I check my...
How do I check my trophy?
Alright.
Where's my lodge?
Where the fuck is my lodge?
I need a...
I need...
How do I...
I need a look at my taxidermy.
I don't know what...
I was like...
I had to buy the DLC?
Oh, create lodge.
Where is it?
I can't create it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I need to go to my lodge.
I fucking did it.
I killed a fox.
I killed...
Oh my god.
A miracle.
Alright.
I'm here to find the fox.
Where is he?
Where is this fucker?
Where the fuck is he?
I need to know.
Where did I...
Where is he?
Where is my fucking fox?
I've chased him for 80 years to get him here.
I have to place it down?
How do I place it down?
Switch to...
How the fuck do I place down my deer?
Where's my fox?
Where is he?
Where the fuck is this...
I paid 3000 dollars.
Where is he?
I have to place him...
I want him displayed right here.
Where did my fox go?
I paid so much money for this.
They can't do this to me.
I actually paid so much money.
I don't care about the bison or the jackrabbit.
Where the fuck is my fox displayed?
Where is he?
Literally the only thing I care about and he's not here.
Oh my god.
There he is.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I did this.
I fucking did this.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Okay.
Wait.
What pose do I want him on?
Alright.
Let's see.
There we go.
Right before I killed him.
This is how he looked at me.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Yes.
That's right.
I did this.
I did it.
I did it, guys.
I broke his leg.
I did it, everybody.
I broke his leg and now he's displayed here.
I fucking did it, everyone.
I'm so proud of myself.
Oh my god.
I'm so proud of myself, guys.
Okay.
Let's...
Alright.
Wait.
Apparently, you can do a multiplayer.
How do I do a multiplayer?
Alright.
Show me how it's actually done, then.
Thank you for the...
Thank you.
I played the hunt for three hours and all I got was a fox with a broken leg.
That's all I got.
Alright.
How do I...
How do I activate multiplayer?
Main menu.
Alright.
I'm activating multiplayer.
I call that a success, guys.
Honestly, that...
I call...
I think that's a success right there.
It's a success story right there.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait.
Why is it...
Why is it not...
What the fuck?
Why is it not full screen?
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
Multiplayer.
I shall...
Okay.
I'm gonna go to Australia.
Does anyone have Australia?
Someone...
Guys.
Someone create Australia.
Which one is Australia, guys?
Someone create Australia for me.
And call it...
Dragoontown.
I don't know.
Whoever has...
Whoever has the Australia DLC...
Alright.
I'm not buying Australia, guys.
I am not.
Someone call...
Someone create Australia right now.
So...
Oh yeah.
Call it Krakow.
I don't...
Don't call it Krakow.
Alright.
I believe in the dragoons.
Come on.
Someone create Australia right now.
Someone create Australia.
Right now.
Come on.
I know...
I know one of you guys have it.
I know one of you have Australia.
Guys.
Go, dragoons.
Go.
I saw all of you guys judging me.
One of you have Australia.
You guys...
Show me how it's done.
Let's kill a kangaroo.
Alright.
We end it by killing a kangaroo.
I refuse to end stream until we kill a kangaroo.
We got you.
Just wait.
I know you guys have it.
So random.
Who plays this?
Apparently...
A lot of you guys do.
Kangaroo is gonna pop up.
And on the other day, you said someone create Australia.
And Australians were created.
It was created as Doki Wishes.
So...
Athena, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Come on, guys.
What?
Okay.
There are more servers now.
But none of it is you guys.
Just name it dragoons.
It's general hunting tips, Doki.
No, we're killing a kangaroo.
I refuse.
We are gonna kill a kangaroo before we end stream.
Still no dragoons yet.
I know you guys exist here.
I know there is a dragoon here that has a server.
That has...
You'll see.
I know you guys are here.
Forgot to update.
You are very...
Oh, they can't name it?
Wait.
How do I know which one is you?
Oh, it's...
Okay, who is the host?
There is a lot of hosts now.
Which...
Oh, there you go.
I recognize.
I recognize the dragoon name there.
Yeah, John.
Alright, show me how it's done.
Alright, let's get all the professional hunters here.
Let's all kill a kangaroo together.
One for each of us.
Let's go.
Alright, where am I?
Am I in the middle of Australia?
Where the fuck am I?
Why am I in the middle of the road?
Alright, let me turn...
Make sure there is no...
There is no push to talk, right?
I'm making sure there is no push to talk right now.
I know.
There is no VC, right?
I'll make sure.
Alright, let's all get together, guys.
There is only...
Alright.
Our mission today is to kill a fucking kangaroo.
That's our mission.
John, it's your time to shine.
Is there PVP?
I don't know.
Let's test it out.
Oh, yeah.
He is safe.
What?
I had to know.
Where I was aiming at was just a coincidence.
Like, where I was aiming at...
Alright.
We...
No, I didn't.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Let's kill a kangaroo.
Look, accidents happen.
Accidents fucking happen.
How many people?
Two?
Four?
Why are like half of us on the other side of the map?
Where do we go?
Don't you guys have dogs?
Alright.
Yeah, it's just a hunting accident, guys.
Just a little accident.
Alright.
Where do we meet up?
Why is this one guy like 6.11 kilometers away?
Why is he...
Oh shit, there's a feral goat somewhere.
Oh my god, there's feral goats?
What the fuck?
There's wild goats here in Australia?
Australia?
Wait, mate, it's Australia.
Of course there's wild goats here.
Australia does not fuck around.
Do we have car...
Okay.
Alright.
How many people do we have?
Three?
Four?
Five?
Six?
Seven?
Okay.
We're missing...
We have one more slot, I think.
Alright, there we go.
The psycho killer has joined the session.
Okay.
At least we have...
I don't think I trust that guy over there.
We have the psycho killer in our fucking squad.
That's a hell of a team.
Alright, we can't kill a kangaroo with a fucking psycho killer.
Oh my god, there's a kangaroo!
The perfect lobby.
The most normal hunting enthusiast in my hunting game.
Wait, did we do it?
Would it be funny if we just got killed by the kangaroo right there?
Bro, I think Vesper's taking the shot.
Wait, there's another one!
Bro, are we just gonna kill the kangaroo right off the bat?
Like...
Oh my god, look!
There they are!
Oh my god!
Go, go, go!
There they are!
They're running away!
Immediate...
Did we do it?
Is he dead?
Vesper, did you get him?
Did you get him?
He's right there!
Vesper, did you get him, Vesper?
He's on the hunt.
Oh my god, there's another one!
There's another one right there!
There's so many!
There's like...
They're just...
They're just like...
A fucking invasive species right now.
They're like iguanas.
They're everywhere.
Oh my god, let's just kill the entire population of kangaroos.
They're pests.
They're actual pests right now.
I hear gunshots around me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're just shooting all of them.
We each have our own kangaroo kill.
This hunting trip is a success.
Jesus Christ, just hear...
Wait, they drowned dogs?!
What the...
Wait, what's this?
Oh wait, that's someone's dog.
I was like, wait, what's this guy doing here?
Do we do it?
Do we kill him?
What the fuck?
They can drown that's...
Dogs?!
Holy shit.
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with kangaroos?
Like, actually.
Do we do it, guys?
No wonder we're hunting kangaroos.
We're actually about to lose a war on kangaroos like the Aussies did to the rate of birds.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where are they?
Alright, but also, I want the trophy too.
I want...
When we do kill them, I wanna...
I wanna take one of them home.
Wait, someone went on me?
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
Why are you guys harvesting the kangaroos?
Kangaroos, guys.
I see no body.
It doesn't count if there's no body, guys.
Okay, does my gun... can my gun kill a kangaroo?
It can't, right?
I think I need an actual gun.
Can I use somebody else's gun?
No.
Wait, I wanna see a dead kangaroo real quick, guys.
Alright, is that him?
Alright, everybody.
Gather around.
Wait, I can't...
Gather around, everyone.
Gather around to this dead kangaroo that I killed.
I killed... I killed this kangaroo, everyone.
As you can see, this is my kangaroo kill right here.
And you can tell it's mine because... wait, where did you...
You can tell it's mine because...
I saved the harvest.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
I know, I took the shot.
Alright.
Thank you, everyone, for watching me kill this kangaroo.
Oh, you wanna take a picture?
Oh, okay, let's go.
I'll kill another one.
Don't worry.
Let's go.
Let's find another kangaroo.
And we can take a picture.
Don't worry.
Let's find another one, guys.
Let's...
Wait, are there koalas?
Is there koalas in this map?
Can we shoot...
Can we shoot a koala?
Find the koalas, please.
That's what they said about the bisons, too.
Look, this is my nature reserve.
Oh, there's another kangaroo.
Oh, there's more.
No, I meant...
Sorry, I meant the drop bears.
I meant the drop bears, guys.
Drop bears are free reign.
Okay, Australia have like multiple problems.
It's not just...
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, it's a feed zone.
Oh my god, we're just shooting.
Guys, I think my golden retriever might be useless.
Why does everybody have...
I like how everyone has bloodhounds and then mine is just...
Mine's a golden retriever.
He's just there.
He's there.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm helping.
I'm heading over.
I took a shot.
See, look.
Look at that.
I'm helping.
I got you guys.
Golden retrievers are just good boy.
It is what...
Me, John, Cryowolf, Dragon, Ninetales, Big, and PsychoKiller172.
The real squad.
I'm suppressing fire.
Careful, the koalas are dangerous.
They have chlamydia.
Oh yeah, they do.
They have chlamydia and they also have like...
The food they're eating is actually not good for them.
Oh, you guys didn't know that?
Yeah.
All koalas have chlamydia.
Did we do it?
Where are they?
Yeah, they were just like born that way, I guess.
You guys didn't know that?
Yeah.
And then eucalyptus leaves actually just make them like incredibly high.
So they're like high and also have chlamydia all the time.
Where the fuck are the kangaroos?
Yeah, it's why they sleep all day.
They're literally just high all the time.
You know what?
I think if I know anybody...
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I was gonna say if I...
If I know anyone that's gonna have a kangaroo, it's gonna be PsychoKiller.
I was like...
I was like, I'm pretty sure PsychoKiller found a fucking...
Got killed a kangaroo.
All right, guys.
I did it, everybody.
I killed another kangaroo.
Look.
Guys.
Okay, everyone.
Everyone.
He's still moving.
So I have to shoot him again, guys.
Guys, look.
Okay.
As you all see.
I killed this kangaroo.
It was still moving.
It was...
So I had to make sure he was dead dead.
Okay, look.
See, I shot him right there on the tail.
All right, everyone.
All right, take a photo, everybody.
Take a photo of this kangaroo that I got right here.
All right, who's taking a photo?
Take a photo of my kill.
All right, is anyone...
All right, are you guys taking a photo?
Yeah?
I did it, guys.
I did it.
Me and my kangaroo.
All right, everybody got a photo?
Okay.
All right, nice.
Now, let me claim my trophy that I clearly got.
All right.
Thank you for watching me hunt a kangaroo.
Can we visit other people's lodges?
Guys, is it possible to visit other people's lodges?
Or no?
Yeah, twice even, guys.
I did it twice.
Exactly like those rich people.
What do you mean?
I did it, guys.
I did it.
Wait, you can?
All right.
Who has the best lodge?
Actually, I want to visit...
Like, I want to visit Psycho Killer's lodge.
I want to know what he's hiding down there.
I want to know what Psycho Killer has in his fucking lodge.
If it isn't Psycho, I'd go there and call...
Sorry, can't show you the basement.
Come on.
Show us your lodge, Psycho Killer.
What's in the basement?
What's in the fucking basement?
All right.
No, no, no.
Let's look at Psycho Killer's first.
He looks like he has something he's hiding.
He definitely looks like he's hiding something.
Dude, he has something to hide.
He is running.
Matt's running around with shotguns after K- Wait, did he kill a kangaroo with a fucking shotgun?
Holy fucking shit.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Okay, maybe these guys are scarier than I expected, guys.
He wants to tidy up.
He wants to tidy it up.
Wait, how do you visit other people's lodges now?
How do you visit other people's lodges?
How do we do it?
Oh my god, the Pharaoh.
That poor goat.
That poor fucking goat.
How does that work, guys?
I want to go visit a lodge.
I want to visit someone else.
God, a goat.
Okay.
He just randomly- Oh, they have to host it as a server.
All right, guys.
Who is hosting it?
Oh, I'm hosting my lodge?
All right, guys.
All right, let's go to John's lodge then.
Oh, Big Bishi- Okay, let's go to Big Bishi and meet him.
I'm going to that one.
They hosted it.
He chased it down.
All right, I'll see you guys at his lodge, guys.
Party at his lodge, everybody.
Party at Big Bishi-man's lodge.
What a fucking sentence.
We're partying over there, guys.
To the lodge we go.
All right.
No party like a lodge party.
Let's see.
Let's see this.
All right.
Oh, wait, no.
Multiplayer.
How do I find lodges?
Wait, how do you find lodges?
Okay.
Big Worldwide.
I'm trying to find server.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
All right, guys.
Party at his lodge, everybody.
I found it.
I'm sad we never got to see Psycho Killer's lodge.
I want to know what's in it.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Hey, that's the fox I killed, too.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
This man's been hunting.
He got a boar.
He got some deers.
Man, that's a nice-ass lodge.
Why am I holding a phone like this?
What is this?
The Rocky Mountain Elk.
Oh, my God.
He has all the ducks, too.
Oh, not the Canadian geese, though.
Mallard.
Yeah, where's the Canadian geese, bro?
Oh, look at all the deers he killed.
Oh, my God.
There's a turkey, too.
He has an eastern wild turkey.
All right, there's...
Oh, my God.
He got, like, a mountain lion.
A puma.
And a red deer.
What the fuck?
You can hunt lions?
Oh, my God.
Wait, he got a lion.
He's got a lion in here.
And a fucking grizzly bear.
Bro, this man's rich.
This man's rich-rich.
Whoa, Simba died.
Okay, but did he get a...
Okay, but did he get the caribou?
Okay, he got the bison.
Never mind.
That's the wild turkey.
Why do you have two turkeys?
Then he has the bison.
Look at that.
See?
He hunted the bison, too, guys.
Wait, what about kangaroos?
Where's your kangaroos?
Where's your kangaroo, buddy?
The mythical caribou.
All right, but where is this caribou, huh?
But does he have...
Does he have a caribou, though?
Not a real gamer.
Doesn't even...
Oh my god, wait, they have albinos?
Wait.
They exist in this game?
They're real?
Why does he have, like, 300 mooses?
Like...
Yeah, but where's your caribou, though?
A shiny...
Oh my god, he got a shiny.
You know what?
I'm not as impressed.
There's no caribous in here.
Sorry, but...
Oh wait, never mind.
Never mind, I'm impressed now.
Okay, never mind.
I found your caribou.
I found two of your caribous.
Never mind.
He hunted 4,000.
Oh my god.
Bro, he got a shiny moose!
Oh my god, the caribou room.
Wait, that's...
I didn't realize you can hunt shinies in here.
Oh my god.
Bro is...
Bro, this man's rich, bro.
This man's rich rich.
Bro was lost in his own home.
Why is there so many moose?
Wait, do you have a shiny lion?
Do you have any other shinies?
Did you catch any other ones?
Any other shiny animal?
Or is it just the moose?
Or the caribou?
Do you have any other...
No shiny lion yet.
Oh yeah.
Wait, he played this game for 6 years?
Jesus.
Oh my god.
See guys?
Um...
I'm not bad.
I'm just inexperienced.
Look.
I'm not bad.
I'm just inexperienced.
I'm just inexperienced guys.
I just didn't play this game for 6 years.
Okay?
That's different.
That was fun.
I had a fun time.
I hope you guys had fun watching.
Watch me...
Try and fucking kill a stupid animal for 3 hours.
Look.
I did kill 3 things.
4 things.
5.
Including the kangaroo.
2 kangaroos that I killed guys.
I did kill 5 things within 3 hours.
Okay?
And I call that an accomplishment.
I had fun.
And...
Yeah, we all gotta start somewhere.
Right?
We all gotta...
Yeah.
I mean, I do it.
I do have them.
I have the kangaroo.
Okay?
I mean, I do.
Look.
See?
I have...
Wait.
Look at that.
The eastern gray kangaroo.
That I own.
See?
I own that guy.
But...
I'm gonna call it here.
We do have another stream tonight.
At...
In 2 hours.
So, I'm gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had fun watching.
Me play the...
The...
And trying to track the animals today.
But I hope you guys all had fun watching.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
Or stay up for Goodnight Dragons.
I'll see you guys there.
I usually do, like, an after stream talk.
Cause I've been feeling...
I've been feeling good lately.
So, like, my...
Well, my voice is not, like...
The...
My voice is, like, not fully recovered.
Since it's still, like, a bit scratchy.
But...
Um...
I'm feeling a lot better.
So...
Um...
But, because we do have another stream tonight...
I'm gonna do, like...
I'm just gonna push the after stream talk over there.
Anyway, guys...
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!